les critères qui ont été utilisés pour
définir
les zones dans plus sous denses c'est
l'accès aux soins donc c'est un critère
qui s'appelle apl et qui comporte le
nombre de consultations disponibles par
médecin le temps que va mettre un
patient pour accéder à un médecin et le
nombre de consultations par tranche
d'âge
à la précédente mesure qui date de 2018
nous l'étions à 30 33 % de déserts
médicaux on a doublé encore il ya des
zones qui pointent leur nez alors
qu'avant du coup c'est les yvelines il
ya les yvelines qui a qui aggrave la
situation
[Musique]
la moitié des médecins et de france a
plus que 60 ans et le car plus que 65 en
dix ans on a perdu
3742 médecins dans la région et on a
réussi à en installer à peu près 900 la
moyenne hebdomadaire de travail des
médecins généralistes à 16,58 donc les
génies se projette pas sur ce modèle là
rendre plus attractive la médecine
libérale avec un simple un simple geste
déjà ces deux de se mettre la
consultation en france du médecin
libéral à la moyenne de l'europe qui est
plus autour de 50 euros coûte que 25 23
on nous met davantage d'un terne
jusqu alors c'est vrai que l'île de
france comme étant considérée comme bien
dotées n'a pas bénéficié des
augmentations
de postes d'un terne qui ont été
accordés dans les autres régions et du
coup il n'ya pas d'adéquation tellement
entre les besoins des territoires et le
nombre d'intérêts
[Musique]